a lot in there which we can unpick in a
bit but I've got Angie Rayna the ducky
labor leader uh with me so let's let's
go straight to her and see what she
thought of the speech
um Angie Rayner it seems to me that this
is a labor party that now finally
believe that you're going to win the
next general election yeah it was
absolutely brilliant to hear care so
powerfully talk about how his passion
and his own life story has informed why
he believed you know that core
investment in Britain in our companies
you know in the future of our economy in
a really strong way that is gonna you
know really power us not just for this
generation but giving hope for our
children which is what we want to see
although it's incredibly inspirational
Andrew though it's fair too to say isn't
it that part of Labor's success in the
polls slightly at the moment is due to
some of the missteps that the public
believe that the conservatives are
taking isn't it rather that they're
unhappy with the Tories than they like
you well I think before this yes
obviously I do think that people have
seen that what the conservatives have
done in the last 12 years certainly the
last week it's got even worse and what
we've set out today and I think what
care has clearly shown is that we've got
a long-term plan for the future of this
country that is going to benefit people
today but also give our children hope
for the future and build our companies
Enterprises partnership with business
you know these are really great ideas
that are going to propel us into the
future on the global stage all right let
me put it another way is it fair to say
that the public are now looking again at
labor but they still don't necessarily
love labor yeah sure I think you know
nobody is complacent air we all know
that in 2019 we've got a real kick in
the public didn't see us as a future but
now they're seeing what the
conservatives have done they're tired
worn out and they've damaged our economy
and they've damaged our our Outlook
internationally now they're seeing a
labor party that understands where we
went wrong and it's got a future plan
that is not going to just help
I've got two more questions sorry Andrew
I got two more questions one the labor
leaders stood on that platform and said
we are the party of the center ground
now you obviously have historically been
associated with the left of the party
that must sting a bit he's a bit too
much Tony Blair the center ground the
party of business the party of
aspiration that's not your politics no
what Kirsten is with a party that's
going to govern for the people of this
country and that's absolutely right look
we can't be in little factions in the
labor party we're a party of government
we're waiting to get into government now
so we can change the lives of the
British people and I think that was
absolutely right that care made that
point today it doesn't bother you when
he says we're the party of the sun to
ground no other party that's going to
win we're the party of government that
was the point that care was making is
that I should do the party for the
British people with a center ground of
British politics we're the people that
are going to get into power out
responsibly and invest in the future
just finally about circus starmer he has
been criticized hasn't he for being a
bit bored in for not connecting with the
public do you think we're beginning to
see a different type of leader do you
think he's changing you see him up close
I think it was great that you saw what I
see you know I've studied men in
interviews if only they could see the
case number that I see the passion the
way he talks about his upbringing the
way he talks about his family and how
he's so passionate to ensure that people
of Britain the companies of Britain the
business the economy that it will grow
together to be something that we can be
really proud of again and I think people
saw in care today what I see all the
time and that's the man that's dedicated
to public duty and wants to see
brilliant Britain prosper and everybody
not nobody left behind you know a
country that is you know tackling
inequality and giving everybody
opportunity and aspiration so Les lawyer
a bit more of a politician these days I
thought that was fantastic I think
people have seen the care that I see
every single day and I've been doing my
lessons I think the public will like it
you know I think he's exactly what we
need in this country at the moment
someone that's got very clear ideas very
good Prince pools and values and ethics
about making sure that we all put our
you know shoulder to the wheel and make
sure that we push forward of Britain
again final question what's your message
today to Liz truss and quasi cuarto do
not completely trash our country before
we take over and make it better fight
and talk there thank you Angela Reyna
thank you so much
um so SJ sorry I'm now in the uh I'm in
the crunch so let's we just move let's
just decide move site out uh well there
you have um Angie Raynor there uh
reflecting really that sense of growing
belief within the labor party that what
a year two years ago felt impossible
really now A distinct possibility for
them that they feel that they are
potentially in touch and distance of
actually winning the next general
election and you can see what's happened
in terms of Boris Johnson and his
political difficulties leading to his
forced resignation there arrival of Liz
truss the economic shift in policy
what's happened now to the economy
that's 17 point lead in that poll the
biggest for two decades not seen since
the days of Tony Blair and Kia stammer
who was being heckled in this Hall a
year ago by the labor left their onstage
channeling Tony Blair using lines from
Tony Blair's speech to put the party
firmly in the central ground a message
to the public that labor can be trusted
on business on the economy
positioning himself as a sober leader I
think the big question the unknown in
all of this and that's what I put to
Angie Rayner is that our labor winning
because the Tories are having such a
torrid time and if the Tories can get
back into control uh can begin to
convince the public of their economic
plans if their economic plans indeed do
begin to grow the economy what does lay
paper do then so certainly here there's
no complacency and there is a fear if
you like that this poll lead could well
get closed over the next two years that
is a long time to the next general
election
and yeah Beth and security uh Dharma
going in hard on the economy as you
would expect given what's happened since
last Friday's mini budget he talked
about reducing debt building a sound
economy fully costed policies and
setting up an office for value for money
but can we just talk about that big
policy announcement that he made and
regarding the new company he wants to
set up within the first year of a labor
government
yeah so this is this is a very
interesting uh announcement that he made
a big a big economic move actually what
labor of announcing is that they are
going to create a new Energy company
basically to invest in Renewables it's
going to be called GB Energy Great
Britain energy it's going to be funded
seed funding from this Sovereign
National wealth fund they've talked
about 8.2 billion earmarked for that
that money some of that they wouldn't
say how much it will be yet will be put
into a new Energy company owned by
taxpayers to invest in the next
generation of energy companies and why
are they doing it well the labor figures
that were talking to us about that
policy say back in the 1980s when oil
and gas was discovered in the North Sea
it was owned by private companies and
then the world from that yes it got paid
in taxes to the government and that paid
for tax cuts under Margaret Thatcher but
what labor is saying is we want the
British people to take the dividends so
they have got a very interesting new
policy it's it's their answer if you
like to list truss's energy security
policy where she says that they want to
issue more licenses for oil and gas
fracking more nuclear more Renewables in
order to make the UK energy sufficient
and an energy exported by 2040 labor is
saying well this is our answer we don't
want to do fossil fuels we want to do
Renewables and their commitment is to
make us a net exporter of energy by 2030
so it's a greens arm race if you like
between the two competitors but that was
his big pitch on the economy and you
heard what he said there we are
believers in business and we want to
work with business again you'll remember
Tony Blair and the prawn cocktail
offensive way went round the city to try
and reassure the markets investors that
labor governments could be trusted on
the economy that was kissed armors
pitched today because he thinks that
because of Liz truss and quasi
qualitan's decision on the economy they
have left an open goal there where the
decades held position by the
conservative party as the party of
economic competence is now in Jeopardy
and Kirsten wants to seize that ground
and Beth I know you're going to be
talking to um other labor MPS they're
there at the party to get their reaction
to to what we've heard but if I could
just ask you another question about
um The Realistic note that secured armor
struck during his speech and the the
deputy leader Angela Rayner has struck
it there when she said her message to
Liz truss was don't trash the country
before we get a chance to fix it um
saying I'd love to say that labor will
fix everything but the damage that the
Tories have done means this time the
rescue will be harder than ever that's
the tone the over the the overall tone
of that speech
I think what Kingston was trying to do
in that speech was put clear blue water
between labor and the conservatives and
he did that in a way where he set out
his agenda but he didn't make very very
pointed political attacks on the
conservatives what I think he really was
trying to do was present himself as a
leader in waiting almost Above The Fray
I think the attempt by kirstarma is to
present himself in a world of increasing
economic and political turmoil as a
steady
Pair of Hands as a safe pair of hands on
the steering wheel and part of doing
that is to not make really pointed
political attacks at your opponents but
there's no doubt that if the economic
strategy that the conservatives are
pursuing doesn't give the growth that
they're hoping and and we should say
that their strategy is you cut taxes you
increase borrowing you give stimulus to
the economy and that pulls you out of
recession that gives you growth that's
their aim we're seeing in the market
turmoil the fears about the knock-on
effect for inflation because it causes
inflationary pressure the knock-on
effect of what that means on interest
rates if investors lose confidence in
government debt that means that the
yields go up so the cost of government
borrowing goes up that means that the
bank of England that's responsible for
monetary policy the government don't
have a saying that they have to put up
interest rates so it is very febrile at
the moment it's unclear how it will play
out and so when you look at the economy
on a two four five ten year plan or
situation it's quite hard to read where
it will go now I should say though the
government have said that they will put
out economic forecasts from the office
of budget responsibility they're
independent on November the 23rd and
they will set out a medium-term fiscal
plan in an attempt to reassure the
government the borrowers over the
government's long-term plan over debt
and the sustainability of their tax and
spend plans some people are suggesting
that they might be have to bring that
forward we simply don't know we have to
wait and see